[موسيقى]
أتلقى تدليكًا كما لو كنت على
طاولة يسترخي جسدي ، ومن دواعي
سروري أنها تعمل
برقبة وكتفي وتحصل على
العقد وأنت تطفو على
سطح الماء الذي يحتضنك  يشبه الأمر
نوعًا ما كونه عديم الوزن ،
فهو مضاد للجاذبية حيث أقوم بتحريك الشخص
عبر الماء ، وهدفي هو جعلهم
مسترخين أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، لذلك من
أجل القيام بذلك ، يمكنني موازنة النظام بأكمله
مع العلاج بالضغط الذي أقوم
به لتخفيف الضغط  يجب
أن يكون لدينا الماء بدرجة
حرارة محددة بين 92 و 98 درجة
مما يسهل استرخاء العضلات
وكل شيء يتحرك بشكل أفضل كثيرًا نرى
أشخاصًا ليسوا رشيقين جدًا على
الأرض وعندما يدخلون الماء يكونون
قادرين على الحركة  بمزيد من الحرية ، يكون الألم
أحيانًا عند المستوى الخامس
، وعندما أخرج ولا
أشعر بذلك ، يمكن أن يستمر هذا الشعور لبضعة
أيام وأنا فقط في
مكان أكثر هدوءًا وأكثر هدوءًا.